I believe in love at first sight no real  words only fake ones everything chef I  love that so easy so right this is how  our story goes back  [Music]  I think I might really like him too much  that's perfect if I just keep being the  perfect boyfriend you'll realize I'm not  a maybe I'm the one love is tricky can  we get real for a second  you have questionable taste in friends a  guy needs to protect himself she's lucky  she has me  that rarely knows what's best for her it  scares me to love someone so completely  and not have them love you back I didn't  know who you really are  I've read people wrong in the past  are you following me  I'm on to you I won't let it get in the  way of us  I think you were hiding something  to being crazy  honestly you're lucky to ask me  every relationship has its obstacles to  overcome right  [Music]  [Music]  you